- Oh, he's kissing me.
Oh, he's kissing me.
He loves me.
And I love him.
- I've fed ducks before,
but it doesn't seem
like they appreciate it,
to be quite honest.
- I remember one time I tossed a duck
a whole piece of bread.
He ate the whole piece of bread.
- Birds are fine, I guess.
I don't really have any...
I don't watch birds.
- I don't care about ducks.
- Like, I've seen baby ducks on Instagram,
and they get mad likes.
- So let's go meet the duck!
- I'm nervous.
- I hear him squeaking.
(deep sigh)
- Oh my God, this is pretty awesome.
- Whoa.
- Be quiet, you guys.
You don't want to scare him.
- Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom...
(laugh)
- Huh!
- Oh, oh, oh, oh.
- So soft and so brittle.
- Alright, it's pretty (bleep) cute.
- He yawned!
- Oh! He sneezed!
- This duck is just full of surprises.
- Wait 'til he starts looking.
(camera click)
- Oh, God! He's doing stuff.
- I need, I need... (bleep)
- You guys saw him yawn.
He was doing it again.
- I feel like I'm a jerk.
Sorry I was so...
I was just not used to
seeing little, baby animals.
He's a little baby guy.
- I'm not ready to have a duck.
- Like, I'd be nervous to turn
on a lightswitch right now.
- I feel happier.
The rest of my day is gonna be better.
- Life is a miracle.
It's a miracle that we all
evolved from little things.
But you see it, and just
you want it to be okay.
Can I hold him again, actually?
(upbeat music)
- He made some peeping noises.
Listen to him!
He goes "peep, peep!"